hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round 8 of the 2018 Tata Steel
chess tournament here we have the sole
leader of the tournament so far
structure mama Dion of facing onigiri
onigiri has the white pieces and before
I show the game I would just like to
visit
Gary's remark from an interview after
this game
Gary finished this game a lot a lot
sooner than everyone else so he
commented on Carlson's move work awesome
blunder the piece and he said that it
was definitely a blunder and that he
could see that you know he could see
Carlsen wasn't very happy about it but
that Carson is a piece stronger than
everyone else so Geary basically said
that cousin can beat anyone a piece down
and that this is his time to prove it
and as you've seen in my previous video
Carlsen definitely did prove it so let's
get back to this game give he has the
white pieces like I've said and it's a
very important game for the tournament
rankings as if Gary manages to win this
one he will tie in first place with
Mahmoud yarv and Magnus Carlsen who won
the game as you've seen in the previous
video
so Gary opens with C for the English
opening we have c5 the symmetrical
variation Knight to f3 knight c6 Knight
to c3 and g6 III Knight to f6 v4c
captures in captures and d5 we have C
characters on d5 Knight captures on d5
and Queen to b3 with a double attack on
the knight on d5 mama D our defends the
c6 defending the knight on d5 and we
have Bishop to b5 now Bishop to g7
preparing the castle Giri castles mama D
our of castles and we have Bishop
captures and c6 b captures on c6 and
rook to e1 Queen to b6 by moment they
are off it's a very active square for
the Queen and I centralized Square where
the Queen will be very active
Knight to e4 of course keeping the Queen
away from that very nice square Queen to
b4 and here Gary the clients a trade of
Queens not because he wants the Queen's
on the board because it's simply bad to
capture a queen if you capture a
nightcap
black is already threatening to win some
exchanges here after a move like rook to
d1 Bishop to a6 comes and black gets a
lot of activity for for basically
nothing so as your queen to be for Queen
to c2 by giri and we have a five now a
three taking the Queen away Queen to b6
and night to c5 now rook to e8 and now
Knight to e5 and this knight on e5 is an
excellent piece night and c5 is also an
excellent piece so we definitely don't
want to leave those nights there but
it's very hard to get rid of them you
don't want to play Bishop captures on e5
giving up your very strong dark square
Bishop then you know you will have a lot
of a lot of weak squares here around
your king
so mommy general decides to go f6 here
this does a week in the Kings side a bit
but it's better to get rid of that night
Knight to c4 attacking the Queen and we
have Queen to c7 and Bishop to d2 now
there's a double attack on the a5 pawn
and gear is preparing Queen to a4 to
gain a triple attack on the pawn he 5
now D captures on e5 f captures on e5
and we have come to a 4 now attacking
that point three times we have Knights
to b6 forcing the Queen to either move
or to exchange the night and here giri
exchanges it Knight captures we have
Queen captures attacking the knight on
c5 and here Queen to see for this comes
with check King cast a move now the
queen is also protecting the knight on
c5 and we have Bishop to c3 now this
will be a very very important square for
this Bishop as he will be attacking this
c5 pawn this pawn will not be able to
move because Bishop captures and g7 will
be deadly for black and it also protects
the b2 upon also very important
we have Bishop to a5 Medea of tries to
tries to develop he wants to connect his
rooks get his pieces into the game and
here Gary finds the best move he plays
g4 and what's the idea behind g4 it
seems like he's just offering Mamedov to
win a pawn it seems like Bishop captures
on g4 Queen captures on g4
and Queen captures and c5 seems
reasonable the problem is after Bishop
captures Angie for you don't capture the
bishop immediately you first play Knight
to a4 now the queen is attacked and the
bishop is attacked and there is there's
no way for queen to defend the bishop so
I have to replace something like Queen
to b5 simply capture the bishop and the
queen is now also protecting the knight
and a 4 so black just lost the piece and
the game so after g4 he goes back he
can't really go back to e 6 the Queen at
night and are defending that square
Knight is defending d7 also so
unfortunately he has to go back to c8 so
Bishop to c8 and here we have rook to e4
adding more protection to the spawn here
as you can see Gary mama doesn't have
the F pawn or the D pawn to her as this
Rookwood upon and is preparing rook 8
you want to double up rooks and e-file
and really go for this C five point
Queen to b5 offering an exchange of
Queens and Geary ignores this he simply
doubles up as this is much more
important Queen captures on c4 rook
captures on c4 and rook to b8 now and
this does activate the rook but what's
the rook really doing nb8 it doesn't
seem that he will ever be able to do
anything as this Bishop is doing a
wonderful job guarding this BTO pawn and
the Medeiros pawn structure is simply
terrible he has he has holes everywhere
this is an isolated point this is an
isolated point this is an isolated pawn
and soon another isolated pawn will be
created we have h3 by Gary defending
that g4 pawn and here we have h5 whether
it's a good decision or not it's hard to
say if anything he thought about
probably after he recaptures and he
recaptures that the bishop will now be
on the h3 pawn but this actually only
creates another weakness for black
so we have G captures on h5 by Gary G
captures on h5 and not rook to h4
defending his h3 pawn and attacking the
h5 point and if you look at the pawn
structure now okay Gary's pawn structure
isn't you know
spectacular but look at the media
response structure a weak bond an a5 all
of
pawns or isolated pawns there are four
point Islands this pawn is attacked this
pawn is attacked this pawn will soon be
well it's its attack but it's very hard
for a for Mammadov to do anything here
here am a media of played King to h7
this is what the idea that if giri
captures the h5 pawn for example rook
captures then he can play king to g6 and
after rook to h4 then Bishop to f6 and
this will give ma media of some activity
back for upon as the rook is now
attacked it has to move the bishop will
be again attacking the h3 pawned the
rooks can come into the game
unfortunately for him after this King to
h7 move giri played Knight to e4 and it
was in this position after giri play
Knight to e4 that ma media of resigned
the game why did he resign there was no
any immediate crushing move for giri
here but there is nothing for black to
play this rook is useless here this rook
doesn't really have any way in any ideas
so we're where it wants to go it can go
to d8 but it's not really useful there
you don't have a good square to develop
your bishop you can go to e6 if you go
d7 that's just weird okay let's let's
see if you can maybe play Bishop to a6
rope simply captures on h5 after King
moves rook to e3 this rook is now coming
to g3
hard to say what black can play here
rook to e7 rook to g3 now King moves now
Knight to d6 preventing black King any
escape routes and the Gary will probably
check the King here forcing him back the
g8 and then capture the e5 pawn the
bishop and g7 will be penned this will
then release gear is c3 Bishop and this
will be crushing for black there is
there's nothing for black to play here
again after this Knight to e4 move
what's what's the other idea black can
go for there is this may be the
straightforward defense of King to h6
but if King to h6 then you have a you
have a couple of ways to approach this
maybe Bishop to detail check but then
this leaves the defense of the b2 pawn
so King to h2 probably King to h2
preparing this rook to come to g1 and
then cut off the King completely for
example a rook to b8 now rook to g1
Bishop to e6 trying to help out with
defense of this h5 pawn but now Knight
the g3 and here's the problem you can't
defend d h5 point if you play something
like Bishop to f7 then comes Knight to
a5 check you move then check comes you
move again you lose the piece and you're
getting checkmated here captures Kings
here
rook g7 check King f8 and rotate
checkmate so although there isn't really
any move that immediately wins whatever
black plays like loses very soon so my
material did not want to continue this
game he resigned and Geary now is tied
in the first place with Magnus Carlsen
and chuckler my madera would five and a
half points you already heard that in my
previous video but in case you haven't
seen it
that's the standings now I was very much
looking forward to maybe showing a holy
fun game against Fabiano Caruana but she
she didn't have any luck in today's game
either she lost she she played the
longest game and it was a it was a rock
ending and in the end she had resigned
due to being two points down in the
endgame or maybe even three points I
think it was actually three pawns down
so yeah so far she only has two draws
this is round eight but thirteen rounds
there's still five more runs to go a lot
of things can happen here so yeah that's
the game and like the title says no more
giri jokes you know it's been a long
time since Geary it was a was the artist
who drew every game it seems that those
days are over as this is his third game
in the title still chess tournament
third win out of 80 games three wins and
five draws no losses that's that's a
pretty pretty amazing result in such a
such competition so yeah I would like to
think you're done is toggle Ari this for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here both will be from the Tata
Steel chess tournament thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon